hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy i'm kristin disarro the chief
learning officer at khan academy and
today i am looking forward to talking
with dr thomas guskey about many things
learning related uh but particularly
grades and grading and reporting systems
before we get started i have a couple
things to remind you of first khan
academy is a non-profit organization and
we are able to do our work
thanks to donations from folks like you
if you go to khanacademy.org
donate
you can help us be able to continue to
do the work that we do
thank you for doing that
second i want to recognize some of our
corporate sponsors who have particularly
helped us in the covid19 crisis
including a t general motors and vastly
and finally if you want to hear this
conversation or other conversations that
sal or i have had with folks in the
education industry or outside of talking
about education related things you can
find us on
your podcast app at homeroom with sal
the podcast
so with that i am glad to welcome dr
thomas guskey he has written over 25
award-winning books but his latest is
get set go
creating successful grading and
reporting systems so we'll be talking
about that he's also the professor
emeritus in the
college of education at the university
of kentucky where he served as
department chair head of the educational
psychology area committee and president
of the faculty council
he began his career in education as a
middle school teacher and earnest
doctorate at the university of chicago
under the direction of professor
benjamin bloom and served as an
administrator in chicago public schools
before becoming the first director of
the center for the improvement of
teaching and learning at national
research center so
welcome thank you for joining us today
thank you kristin i've been a long
admirer of the work of the khan academy
so this is quite an honor for me thank
you oh it is an honor for us to have you
i'd like to get started in talking to
folks a little bit about their career
paths so
as you think about how you ended up
being a professor and researcher
studying the things you study how did
you get there what did you say when you
were a kid that what you wanted to be
when you grew up and how did that evolve
well i had a very different career path
than most people in education my
undergraduate major in college was
actually physics and electrical
engineering
but i graduated from college with my
degree in that area to discover
that i have no talent in that field at
all
it was a terrible disappointment to my
father who is an engineer
and i was at a party one night
which i i did a lot at that time uh
talking to a friend who told me about a
teaching job he'd been looking for a
teaching job and it was in private
school middle school where they needed a
seventh and eighth grade math teacher
would also coach
and this just happened to be the third
week of august
so
because my father
always claimed that the only reason i
was hired is i passed a mirror test they
put here my nose had fogged and so i got
the job
but i started teaching middle school and
i just fell in love with it i know a lot
of people struggle with that age of
children but i i just thought they were
terrific
so as a contingency of me being hard i
had to gain my certification so i began
taking education classes then i gained
my certification
and then after several years decided
that i really wanted to go back to
graduate school to learn how to become a
better teacher so i began in in boston
and then ended up at the university of
chicago where my chair my advisor and
the chair of my doctoral dissertation
committee was benjamin bloom
so it was from that
that i really became interested in the
whole area of of educational
measurements evaluation uh learned about
the taxonomy learn about instruction and
mastery learning and then began working
with chicago public schools did that for
several years and
decided after that i really wanted to go
into university position so
i accepted a position here at the
university of kentucky in the department
of educational
school and counseling psychology
and where i spent most of my academic
career
fantastic
so as i alluded to you have written a
lot of books and articles and
impressive library so if you had to pick
out some of the the areas that you think
that you say hey
i have a lot to to say about this topic
what are some of those areas that you
feel like are
important to that that you have some
important things to talk about
right
well my very first book was on
implementing mastery learning
and this was an extension of what i had
learned with benjamin bloom he was the
person to develop the whole concept of
mastery learning
and then when i began working with
chicago public schools we were leading a
team of of people there really to
implement bloom's ideas into the public
school system in chicago
so that was really my first interest the
instructional programs and the idea of
of using assessments as learning tools
but my my dissertation was actually in
the area of change and teacher change in
particular
so that led me into a profound interest
in none of the change process but
teacher learning and professional
learning experiences for teachers
so uh developed a book developed an
evaluation model for
professional learning looking at how we
can translate professional learning for
educators into
learning for students
um
then that
from that
got me interested in sort of using
assessments as learning tools as we had
through mastery learning that took in
the area of assessment
and then when we gather that information
we have to report it and communicate it
to parents and to families and that
brought me into theory of grading and
that's really what i've been focusing on
for the last several years of grading
issues and how to really enhance that
understanding what we know about the
grading process and then how we can
improve it to
enhance the communication between
schools and homes
that totally makes sense and i see how
things built on each other to get to
where you are today so before we get to
the grading piece i'd love to talk a
little bit more about mastery learning
since it is also at khan academy a
foundational uh piece in terms of how we
think about it so for those who are
watching who don't know um dr benjamin
bloom is considered one of the pioneers
and then dr gusky has taken many of
those lessons and applied them and
shared them with the world as well
how do you when you're when you went in
and were first talking to teachers or
even now when you're talking to teachers
who are just learning about mastery
learning how do you introduce it to them
in terms of what are the main the key
points and the key elements of it
well i always introduce mastery learn to
teachers as
a way to solve the two biggest problems
the teachers face
uh the first being the whole notion of
motivation you know how do i how do i
motivate students to learn things that
they may not consider importing their
lives or
don't seem as as relevant
and the idea is that the key to
motivation and what we know
seems to be the foundation of building
motivation is success i mean students
persist in activities which they're
successful and they
avoid with passion those things in which
they're not successful or believe they
cannot be
i mean i always
use the example of video games
i mean the biggest selling video game of
all time is pac-man
i mean nothing has ever outsold pac-man
it's a
like a 17-18 billion dollar uh industry
and the purpose of pac-man is basically
to gobble up dots
now
what makes that interesting what makes
that relevant to anybody's life nothing
and then some people say well maybe it's
behavioral maybe it's based on the
rewards you get
but that's not true
i mean in pac-man
what do you get if you gobble up all the
dots
you get more dots
that's a great word that's like saying
look do these ten problems right i'll
give you ten more to do
so but what pac-man did is it it showed
people that they could be successful at
this task
and capitalized on that success every
time they'd improve and make the
challenge a little bit greater and so
you can succeed at so that's the same
that what we have to carry through in
education we have to find ways we can
help students succeed
and see that they can be successful as
learners
but that ties to the second major
problem and that problem is
the diversity that teachers face in
group based instruction
i mean it would be great to think about
individualized instructional programs
but we'll never be able to get to a
situation in our country where we have a
class size of one
you know it's always going to be group
based and because of that diversity in
there is no matter what approach a
teacher chooses it works for some it
doesn't work for others
and so teachers have to find a way to
provide for the diversity of needs in a
group-based environment
and those are exactly the two conditions
under which benjamin bloom
developed the ideas of mastery learning
what could we do in a group-based
environment to help more students learn
excellent the things we have to teach
and gain the many positive benefits of
that success
so i think it's an approach as a way of
solving those two critical problems the
teachers face
and giving them a solution to an issue
with which they've always been familiar
and probably have always struggled
i continue to hear those as probably the
two biggest questions that we get from
teachers how do i help differentiate for
all the different levels i have in my
class and how do i motivate students so
that absolutely makes sense in terms of
the problems uh to be solved and where
those were
that it continues to
over over years that continues to be
some of the issues that teachers face
when you were first starting
so don't want to make you feel
old but you've been doing this for a
while
yes that's true what were some of the
what were some of the you know the
conditions then and how do you see
things either changing or the same in
the world in the school environments now
well uh
it certainly has changed a lot i mean i
i
have the advantage of now with social
media many of my former students middle
school students are now my friends on
facebook and they write to me about
their lives and what's going on
and the
the
the positive ways in which education has
changed especially through the use of
technology it's just remarkable the
things that we're able to do today
um but
the social conditions are really
different and but teachers are i think
very sensitive to that and aware
of the things that our students bring to
school and how we have to help them
use school as an environment in which
they can feel safe
and in in the safety of that environment
really become successful in in learning
and i think that's where where benjamin
bloom
where they made a remarkable difference
that he said that learning in any
subject area is infinite and there's no
limit to what you can learn in any
subject area at all
but a curriculum is finite
and when we identify a curriculum what
we do is we take that entire domain of
learning in any academic discipline or
subject area
and we specify these are the things we
think all students should be able to
learn really well
and then once we do that our job as
educators becomes
doing everything within our power to
ensure that all students not just some
but really all
learn that excellently
and so where where bloom really differed
in his orientation compared to others is
that at that time when he developed
these ideas in the late 1960s and early
1970s
people were talking about equality of
educational opportunity and doing things
to make sure that all kids had similar
opportunities when they entered school
and bloom
saw that as just an impossible sort of
thing that no matter what we did our
society was going to dictate that kids
would come to school dramatically
different
and what we needed to do was not concern
ourselves so much with the quality of
opportunity but but equity in terms of
the outcomes
and what could we do to ensure that all
students regardless of the conditions
they brought with them to school
were able to learn excellently and so
they would master that curriculum
gain the benefits of learning success
and be able to carry that over to what
they then would have in their lives
that absolutely makes sense as we think
about equity and um and equality and
that those are certainly themes that
we're seeing playing out in schools
today
as you know as
sailing as they were then i think they
continue to be
uh as we think about that equality i
know one of the struggles that teachers
have in classrooms is
thinking about when students have those
gaps that need to be filled in their
foundational knowledge
and they also have the pressure teachers
have the pressure of
meeting those
grade level standards and i have to
cover all this material this year how do
you help teachers think about that
tension
well i think one of the things that i
try to emphasize in in my work is that
we're never going to be able to overcome
all those gaps that students might have
when they come in
and i think it's really a folly to to
try to look back and think about all
that you might have missed
what's much more productive is to look
ahead and with each learning unit try to
identify the maybe two or three things
that students need to have
in order to succeed in this next unit
uh they don't you're not going to remedy
like three years of learning deficits in
the the first six months of school but
what you can do is look ahead to that
first instructional unit and say
in order for the students to really be
successful to start at a level playing
field
here are the two or three things they
really need to learn
these are the things they really need to
have this would establish a baseline for
them this would be the prerequisite for
it
and then what we do is we teach those
two or three things to a level of
mastery
and then
everybody's starting on that level
playing field when you get everybody
starting in a level playing field then
you can guarantee
success in that first unit
and typically success in the first unit
is prerequisite for success in the
second unit although in the second unit
you might again look ahead and identify
if there were any things that i would
expect students to know and be able to
do
to really succeed in this one and i
could take a little bit of time
and what we find is that if teachers can
do that to look ahead
rather than looking back and take a
little bit of time at the beginning of
every instructional unit to
really emphasize those prerequisites
not only does it mean their instruction
can increase in its pace later right but
it gives kids the necessary
preconditions for success
so it's it's the idea that instead of
remedying problems from the past we look
ahead to what kids need and then provide
that in a really structured environment
and then be able to build on that as we
go along
all right i rarely i don't like to use
these to plug uh khan academy things but
i just wanted to run this by you so we
have what we call get ready for grade
level courses which essentially your six
you have your sixth grade course say you
have a unit on decimals
the get ready for course has the get
ready for decimals unit which has those
two or three prerequisites that you need
to do decimals and that we want teachers
to use in that way and and are leaving
them in so
we have read what you're suggesting and
taking that in and built um built on
that so
chris one of the reasons i'm such an
admirer of the khan academy work because
it's so thoughtfully structured and you
do such a very good job of building on
exactly those ideas those get ready
things are just absolutely on target and
just precisely what we would need to do
to ensure that higher level success for
our students
yeah yeah uh
always always excited to hear folks
saying talking about the things and i
can say
yes we're trying to do that
he was so thoughtful in design
uh absolutely let's move into talking a
little bit about grading and where
you've been
writing and thinking about grades and
grading
what what would you say are
the big factors in effective and
accurate grading
well
we actually
did a very large project in 2016 where
the american educational research
association was celebrating its 100th
year anniversary
and as a part of that celebration they
put out a call to the field to
researchers and scholars to ask
if they would take on the the challenge
of
really reviewing all the research being
conducted in these different areas of
education over that 100 year period
so together with my friend susan
brookhart we put together
an amazing team of really important
scholars that had looked into the
grading area and asked them to take on
that challenge
and we developed our paper which was
published in review of educational
research and then actually extended that
into the practical implications of that
work in a book we did for ascd called
what we know about grading
but what surprised us most in getting
into this area was to discover how much
we know
how long we've known it
and how little of that has found its way
into practice today i mean i've grown
absolutely convinced there's just not
another area in all of education where
the gap between our knowledge base and
our practice is greater than in the area
of grading
and so we've we've got an amazing
knowledge base it gives us guidance on
how to do this well it's just that we
are so bombed by tradition
that it's very difficult to challenge
those traditions and implement change in
this area that is is so sort of
confirmed in our practices in the past
that it's hard to break
so what are some of those things that
you would do differently or that we need
to change and how we're thinking about
grading
well there are three things in
particular that we need to do number one
we really need to have educators sit
down and establish the purpose you know
why why are we doing this in the first
place
researchers have asked that question in
studies that they've conducted and find
that that we are all over the place and
why we're doing it in the first place
and that means that there's great
diversity then in policies and practices
because teachers believe they're doing
it for different reasons
and then when we study parents or
students and ask them their greatest
concerns about fairness and grading
the number one problem that they always
identify
is
the inconsistency among teachers in the
same school
the only way to establish that
consistency is to start by defining your
purpose
and so it means that school leaders need
to sit down with their faculty and and
really hash out these differences and
come up with a consistent
purpose statement of poem which we can
all have consensus and then we look at
our policies and practices and see if it
lies with that purpose
then second
we need to
recognize that
we combine all these diverse elements
when we grade students we've we've found
that there are three different types of
criteria that teachers use in grading
students so we've labeled those
product
process
and progress
product criteria are
sort of common administrations of
learning you don't worry about how they
get there you worry about what they've
learned what they have to do
process criteria are actually behaviors
that enable learning
and so if you count homework you're
grading in terms of process if you count
class participation
if you count formative assessments of
those are process criteria
and finally we have progress with
progress you don't worry so much about
where they are but how far they've come
how much improvement they've made
so be possible for
a student to make excellent progress but
still be achieving below grade level
now we know that all three of those are
important
what gets us into trouble is when
teachers combine all three into a single
grade
because then the grade is impossible to
interpret
i mean she got a high grade what does
that mean
it doesn't mean she learned anything
well
maybe
maybe it just means she tried really
hard or if you know where she started
she's come so far during this time
and so the second thing
is we need to move away from a single
grade to
multiple grades
we need to give students multiple grades
to represent these different types of
criteria so they'll get an achievement
grade
and we can still use that for gpa and
all the kind of things we are important
but maybe give a separate grade for
homework or a separate grade for class
participation
now
although that sounds like a lot of extra
work what's amazing is if you go to
other places around the world
if you go to northern europe and the
scandinavian countries
if you go to places in asia
if you go to schools in canada
they have done it for decades
we are one of the few developed nations
in the world that persist in this idea
of combining everything into a single
grade
and when i asked the canadians with whom
i worked about the extra work they said
actually it's easier than what you silly
people do in the states
i mean we collect the same information
as you
we just don't worry about combining it
at the end so all those arguments you
have about
weighting things we don't deal we keep
it separate the teachers love it
because they find it's so much easier to
explain students performance in school
when these things are are separate
they find the kids pay a lot more
attention to things like homework and
class participation when it's not
disguised in an overall sort of
conglomerate grade the parents like it
because didn't profile the ones their
kids
college universities love it
because all grades are carried over to
the transcript and so you get a much
more interesting much
more
sort of complete picture of assad's
performance in school
and the third we want to do is
we need to get down to fewer grade
categories
we need in particular get rid of the
percentage grade system
it's just impossible
for us to get any consistency and grades
with 101 discrete categories of student
performance
just doesn't make sense
and i know a lot of people think well
but it's giving you a fine
discrimination allows us to we're finely
discriminated among students performance
but what we have to understand is that's
only true when you have direct measures
direct measures are things like height
or weight
where if i have a finely tuned scale
then i can measure more precisely but
most of what we measure in school is
indirect
and that means we we give kids a series
of tasks and and a series of questions
to answer and then we infer
from their performance what level of
achievement that represents
so we move for indirect and when you
move to indirect measures then 101
levels
just impossible to do in any any
meaningful way the average amount of
variation among teachers with a
percentage grade system looking at
exactly the same body of evidence it's
10 to 15 percentage points
moon is huge
and so huge yeah
yeah to get consistency we need to get
down to a more much more reasonable
number of categories of student
performance so we can defend and and we
can do much more consistency so those
three things be clear about purpose
multiple grades
fewer categories of performance
that makes sense we have a question from
jorge lille on facebook that says what
are the assessment implications
of this kind of grading what is that
what does that
reveal what we should be doing in terms
of assessment practices
well it does imply that if you're going
to
actually evaluate or judge students
performance in these non-academic areas
that we have to have a clear rubric of
what that means
if you choose collaboration is one thing
you want students to be able to develop
then number one
you're going to have to deal with the
parent who comes to you and says you
gave my kid a 2 in collaboration how can
get a 4
and we need to be able to say this is
what level 4 collaboration looks like
this is what an example of level 4
collaboration would be here is how i
would distinguish between those
and what many schools are doing is after
the teachers determine among these sort
of non-academic factors they're going to
consider
that they
turn the job of developing rubrics over
to the students
and the students actually develop these
rubrics where they say okay how can i
show the teachers that i can be
collaborative how can i show the teacher
that i'm responsible how can i show the
teacher that i accept responsibility and
can
be acting in a responsible way
and what we find is that they are
tremendously talented in being able to
define that especially when the teachers
give them some guidance and direction
there
and so you make a really good point we
need to be able to specify that clearly
it's not something we can just make some
judgment of and and have it be out there
we need to be able to do that now when
it comes to these process elements there
are three different times
there is is first of all
what we call these learning enablers
that's what i described earlier and that
would include things like homework
class participation effort formative
assessments and like a third area or a
secondary is what we call the social and
emotional learning skills that would
include things like grit
perseverance growth mindset
all these kind of things we associate
with social emotional learning that's
the third year the third area is just
compliance
the compliance is did you do what i told
you had to do
now again
we don't know at this time among those
what's most important for students we're
just starting to study that now a new
center has been established at the
university of chicago to look into this
harvard university has established the
center to look into social motion
learning skills we do know this you you
can't do it all
and so the means of faculty again has to
sit down and decide their priorities and
among those things what they consider
most important
then you have to develop meaningful
rubrics for it
you have to be able to communicate that
rubric to all the stakeholders parents
and students in particular
and then
make sure that you include that on your
report card in a meaningful way and in
your purpose statement that you're going
to report those things separately
that that absolutely makes sense
in terms of thinking about all of the
pieces that need to fall into place um
we are already almost that time i want
to
do
come make the circle back to mastery
learning i know you've also
have a book uh implementing mastery
learning and uh what that looks like how
do these grading practices and mastery
learning all come together to
you know make that that implementation
of mastery learning happen through these
grading practices
well it's certainly true this new
version of our book on implementing
mastery learning
is
actually a third edition it was my very
first book and benjamin bloom actually
wrote the
uh an issue forward to the book and so
we're taking those those ideas and
adapting them now to a
you know a 21st century format and one
of the things we talk about in the book
is the use of technology within mastery
learning especially as a sort of
instructional advice when you have a
sort of flipped classroom
or especially in corrective activities
where
teachers have tried their best to teach
particular concepts and skills in one
way they need other options and and the
availability of instructional
alternatives through technology now is
so wonderful and so broad that it gives
teachers much more latitude and much
more flexibility in what they can
provide
for students so it's it's trying to
interpret that in the modern context in
which teachers are now working and be
able to use these new tools that we have
in good and productive ways
so we're hoping that that this book will
allow teachers to take those ideas of of
all students funding excellently
the practical ways of accomplishing that
as benjamin bloom described interpreted
in a modern context and giving them lots
of ideas and uh examples from what
successful teachers who are using
mastery learning have found to work
pretty well for them
that sounds great we definitely
not surprisingly feel like technology
can help teachers scale
the kinds of practices around mastery
learning that was difficult even for one
teacher in a classroom of 30 to do and
that technology can be a tool to help
them
scale some of these ideas to their their
classroom sizes so i look forward to
reading more
yeah you're absolutely true uh kristen
in fact that's i think one of the things
that all
educators have learned through the
pandemic
is that you know if you were unwilling
to consider the viability of technology
before now it's a must
you know where and what that did is it
opened the door to all kind of different
possibilities it certainly increased the
demand for those kind of services but i
think it made educators more
sophisticated in determining quality of
those as well
there's a lot out there on the internet
that is not very good
and be able to distinguish those in
terms of the quality programs and i
think that's the other thing that i mean
i
don't mean to be an advertisement for
the khan academy but i think we have
done a really good job of looking at
quality control for these things
and and really trying to ensure
uh through various devices that the kind
of things that you put out there are
things that are going to help students
in ways that are meaningful to them i
think that's a tremendous tremendous
asset
yeah that is fundamentally what we are
about
it is uh already
a past time for us to close up thank you
so much for joining us today and for
sharing your views about mastery
learning and grading with the audience
today
kristin it's been my pleasure to be with
you thank you for this wonderful honor i
do appreciate it and i hope that we'll
have other conversations again
absolutely and thanks to all of you
listening for joining us do stay tuned
tomorrow we have uh chase nortongren uh
who will be joining us from nwea to talk
about goal-setting motivation and how to
start and reset learning routines which
are good things to think about as we
head into summer thank you all and we
will see you next time
you